you're expecting to get to 102 years old
yes
why not
in 1932 90 years ago the first Jewish
person was born right here in the Las
Vegas Valley Roberta Kane better known
as Bobby celebrated a birthday Milestone
from then to now she says both the
Jewish community and Hanukkah
celebrations look much different Ryan
mathe gives us a glimpse of her near
centuries worth of experiences in the
valley
and the captain nearly A Century Of
Memories on Roberta Bobby Kane's kitchen
counter Friday night was for services
but Saturday night was for gin rummy
she just celebrated her 90th birthday in
November it's 90 years young 90 years 90
years old her parents California
transfers who own two liquor stores on
Fremont Street and Charleston in 1932
she unknowingly made Las Vegas history
as the first Jewish person born in the
valley I admit that I have grown up not
knowing some of the songs or the
Traditions a much different experience
than what Jewish children may experience
today Las Vegas at the time had just
over 5200 people not even 200 of them
she says were Jewish we didn't have a
temple here Temple Beth sholom at 16th
and Oakey until 1946 meaning Hanukkah
then mostly isolated to the homes of the
20 or so Jewish families in town now the
Las Vegas Valley is home to an estimated
a hundred thousand Jewish people and
though she says Las Vegas was always
accepting to the growing Community it's
not the same Statewide anti-Semitism
incidents have increased 64 percent in
Nevada since 2020 according to the
non-profit you belong but this holiday
the menorah candlelights Globe bright as
Bobby says the community has never been
more united I would say to the Jewish
Community how proud I am of how it has
grown and and the wonderful people who
are doing so much
and she'll be celebrating the holidays
this season with her congregation she
calls him family when Ryan asked her
secret to longevity she says a healthy
diet daily exercise as well as kindness